non-minimalists
howdy what's your name where you from my
name is aaron i'm from abilene texas
well thank you for being here so um
i guess my question this will be a tough
one i hope i hope i just think it might
be
so 18 year old aaron decided it was
smart to go
to a private school and get a degree in
youth ministry
and now i'm trying to figure out what to
do
with a substantial private school debt
off of you know
service industry pay is there something
you want to do
with the degree that you have earned or
have you decided that you don't want to
do something with that degree
my degree was youth ministry and graphic
design and so
i mean i want to be involved in ministry
i spent four years in the youth camping
industry um
teaching outdoor education i'm a school
teacher now
i don't know it's kind of open to where
god leads me in the ministry field
but just really wanting to get rid of
that debt
but also looking down being like man
they you know charge this
pay youth minister almost nothing yeah
yeah so how much how much that do you
have right now
um i think whenever i look at all the
interest and stuff on there i'm
sitting right around 100 000. okay six
figures worth a day
and at a fifty percent tuition from my
dad being a professor
yeah how much money are you earning
right now i'm a year i'm
as a school teacher i'm earning in the
mid-40s okay
okay so so this isn't impossible it's
not like you don't have
any income right you just need more
income i can tell you one thing that i
did
it certainly wasn't sexy i delivered
pizzas for a while
um
that's because uber wasn't and lyft
weren't available at the time
i i'm pretty sure i would have done that
um
however that that was something i had to
do and i was i had a corporate job and i
was in debt i'm like what am i
i need to get rid of this as soon as
possible because what you're talking
about right now
is you want to untether from your past
and right now
you're unable to untether from that past
because
you you may end up doing something with
with with this degree but you're not
going to do anything with
the debt right the debt it's all a sunk
cost and you wish you wouldn't have
gone into it but we can wish all day now
it's time we have to do
something about it right and so when i
when i look at someone who's in your
situation
you don't just have a debt problem you
have a bit of an income
problem and that means you don't have i
mean i could live fine off of forty
thousand dollars a year it wouldn't be
in los
angeles um but i remember when i first
left the corporate world
uh in dayton ohio i was more financially
secure that year
i took about a ninety percent of my high
eighty percent high eighty so about
ninety percent
pay cut i was making 23 000 a year in
dayton ohio
and i was more financially secure that
year
but the reason being is i didn't have
these heaps of debt and
i spent all of my time attacking that
debt
so that i didn't have to be tethered to
a life i no longer wanted
to lead man i am
i'm thinking to myself like if because i
didn't do the traditional college round
i started school 25 years old because
work paid for it
i was like oh it'd be stupid not to go
work pays for it and then
two years later they stopped paying for
it and now it might be stupid to drop
out so i'm going to rack up some debt
finishing school anyway if i was 18
years old going into it
i would certainly um i would probably
tell my thing
myself things like dude this is this is
a college experience it happens only
once in your life
i want to make sure that i'm going to
like go to the school i want to go to
i'm going to live and the place i want
to live
i deserve to have all of this this great
college experience and i think that
everyone out there deserves to enjoy
their college experience but
we have to be careful uh with that that
word
deserve i know this isn't answering your
question but here's what i'll say
when we do fall into that mode and we do
tell ourselves we deserve it and we
spend four years racking up
uh huge amounts of debt here's my pithy
answer
spending four years of
careless spending will force you
into eight years of careful budgeting
so so right now you're you're at that
you're at that point man like you have
made this bed that you have to land
which is okay like you you're this is
not
undoable you're super young and you've
got
many many years ahead of you but it is
going to take you years to get out of
this of of careful careful budgeting
and it's and it is paying for that four
years of careless spending that you had
but the good news is is that yes if you
come up with a plan
you will absolutely be able to you have
to work that plan though and it's going
to be tough at first you might have to
do some uber driving on the weekends uh
you might have to deliver some pizzas i
wonder what the going rate is for pizza
driver now probably not as much as an
uber yeah
uber drivers make tips now too so i mean
i was in this one
one uber and this guy was just hustling
he was like do you need hand sanitizer
you need a charger for your iphone do
you
here i'm selling these little things for
you know 50 cents or whatever and i'm
not telling you to take it to that
extreme but he was making it work
like and i'm like hey man why are you
selling all this stuff he's like credit
card debt
anthony sabas here man you know y'all
are hitting it on man um
you know first thing is man i want to
commend you for for having a heart for a
ministry because our young people do
need positive
more positive role models in the world
and and i say that because uh man i went
to seminary school to be a youth
minister as well
and i was a youth pastor for 13 years so
on the practical side what i would tell
you is
do exactly what they're saying figure
out that way and maybe look into this
as well figure out how to use your
degree to build your shovel
and your shovel is your income so right
now maybe
figure out since you have a heart for
youth ministry on how to become a very
well-known youth speaker
youth speakers do make good money
traveling around the world
and so if you can really figure out your
message and take your message into
schools colleges churches that could be
some extra income as a school teacher
your shovel just went from forty
thousand to now maybe eighty thousand
instead for taking it you for so long to
get out
i really believe you can do it within
three years if you get
focused and build that shovel up and
anthony one other thing
he mentioned also graphic design right
oh come on man so you you've got you've
got
so it depends maybe part of it is you
you want to speak to the youth but
speaking isn't the only way to speak
right and i mean
you look now we have jess or we have
jordan or we have podcast
hiding in the shadows somewhere ladies
and gentlemen podcast sean
um they're all helping us
speak to people via these different
mediums
and and so one thing that you can do is
is via graphic design via design
is communicate the way you're trying to
communicate and there are
plenty of people who make additional
money you know jordan was
constantly instagram hustling to to make
some more money
on the side so uh it's something you can
do for sure and he ain't cheap either
i know i got my guy in the back i'm
paying him a lot of money right now
and aaron it's i i agree with you man it
probably isn't going to take eight years
but uh but but it you know for as much
time as it took you to get into that
debt it's going to take you some time to
get out of it but brother
you got it man keep asking the right
questions and work your plan like you
will get out of it
maybe maybe the pithy answer there is it
didn't take you a day to get into debt
and it's
not going to take you a day to get out
of debt perfect
that's the answer thank you aaron
[Applause]
thanks